Catedrática Tamar
Gendler: En esta clase
veremos lo que hemos estado estudiando
en la ética de Aristóteles,
la afirmación de que para
cultivar una virtud
debemos cultivar ciertos
hábitos en nosotros.
Primero quiero enseñarles una
imagen de una camiseta
que fue muy popular en MIT, a
mediados de los 90,
cuando mi esposo estaba
estudiando su doctorado ahí.
La camiseta decía:
"La gravedad no es solo una
buena idea, es la ley".
Si ustedes fueran alumnos de MIT
estarían muriéndose de risa.
[risas]
Como seres sociales que son, se
están riendo ante la idea
de que otros seres se ríen de esto.
[risas]
Lo interesante de esta camiseta
es que destaca la diferencia
entre 2 tipos de leyes.
La gravedad no es una ley
que les diga cómo
deberían comportarse.
Es una ley que les dice cómo se
comportan las cosas en realidad.
Los filósofos hacen una
distinción entre 2 tipos de leyes.
Por un lado, hay leyes
normativas, obligaciones,
leyes que les dicen cómo
deberían hacer las cosas,
cosas que expresan, como su
nombre lo indica, normas.
Son cosas como
"mirar hacia ambos lados antes
de cruzar la calle".
Es algo que deberían hacer.
No sería gracioso tener una
camiseta que dijera:
"Mirar hacia ambos lados antes
de cruzar la calle:
no es solo una buena idea, es la ley".
¿Verdad?
Podría ser la ley y la camiseta
no sería graciosa por varias razones.
No sería gracioso tener una
camiseta que dijera:
"No comer en la biblioteca: no es solo
una buena idea, es la ley".
Porque podría haber una ley que
prohibiera comer en la biblioteca.
No sería gracioso tener una
camiseta que dijera:
"100 km/h: no es solo una
buena idea, es la ley"
porque de hecho, es una ley normativa.
Las leyes normativas expresan
juicios acumulativos
sobre cómo deberían ser las cosas.
Son el tipo de leyes que
podemos encontrar
en la facultad de derecho de Yale.
Además, hay leyes de otro tipo
por todo el campus.
Están esparcidas en todo lo que hacen.
Son las leyes descriptivas.
Esas leyes indican cómo son
las cosas en realidad.
Sería medio gracioso tener una
camiseta que dijera:
"Si un carro te atropella, morirás.
No es solo una mala idea, es la ley".
Porque "si un carro te
atropella, morirás"
es una descripción de
cómo es el mundo.
Es un hecho del mundo, es una ley
en el sentido que permite predecir
el futuro basándose en el pasado.
Un hecho que indica las
relaciones tipo ley
entre las cosas del pasado y del futuro.
Asimismo, es una ley de
biología, química y física
que "las migajas pueden causar el
deterioro de los libros".
Es una descripción de un
hecho del mundo a la que
se puede corresponder la ley normativa
de "no comer en la biblioteca".
Pero son afirmaciones muy distintas.
Por último, mientras el límite de
velocidad para conducir tu carro
es 100 km/h, el límite de
velocidad para todo
es 300,000 km/s.
La velocidad de la luz es
una ley descriptiva
de qué tan rápido es posible ir,
mientras que el límite de 100 km/h
es una ley normativa de qué tan
rápido tienen permitido ir.
¿Por qué comencé esta clase de
Aristóteles y el hábito
con un montón de
observaciones sobre la
diferencia
entre las leyes normativas
y descriptivas?
Esta es la razón: los
hábitos son herramientas
para convertir deberes en hechos.
Los hábitos son formas de tomar
las obligaciones normativas
que tenemos sobre cómo
queremos que sean las cosas
y aprovechando el hecho de que
somos seres psicológicos,
biológicos, químicos y
físicos nos creamos patrones
de relaciones a manera de
leyes descriptivas
a través de la repetición de
las mismas actividades.
Cuando Aristóteles dice:
"Aprendemos un oficio cuando
producimos el mismo producto
que debemos producir cuando ya
hemos aprendido el oficio.
Nos volvemos constructores,
construyendo; arpistas, tocando el
arpa;
justos, haciendo acciones justas;
templados, actuando con templanza;
valientes, haciendo cosas valientes"
nos explica la utilidad de
reconocer la conexión
entre las leyes normativas
-formas en que queremos ser-
y las leyes descriptivas -formas en que
nos convertimos naturalmente-.
Recuerden que cuando
Aristóteles describe
cómo cultivar las virtudes,
compara dos casos
que solo están sujetos a
leyes descriptivas.
Dice que no es como intentar
entrenar una piedra para que flote
en el aire, porque eso está
sujeto a una ley descriptiva.
Tampoco es como observar a una
planta desarrollarse
cuando tiene agua y luz
porque eso también
solo está sujeto a leyes descriptivas.
Lo interesante del terreno del medio,
en el que se centra casi todo el
libro de Ética a Nicómaco,
es que en ese terreno está el
principio que acabo de explicar.
Es el terreno en el que podemos pensar
cómo queremos que sean las cosas,
actuar como si ya fueran así
y provocar uno mismo que las
cosas lleguen a ser así.
La idea básica de Aristóteles es que
si quieren llegar a ser algo,
actúen como si ya lo fueran.
Si quieren ser valientes por instinto,
actúen como la gente valiente.
Después, se volverá
natural para ustedes.
Si quieren ser pianistas,
entrenen sus dedos para que actúen
como los dedos de un pianista.
Se aprende el arte de tocar,
produciendo el producto
que se debe producir cuando ya se ha
aprendido a tocar el piano.
Aprenden a ser pianistas,
practicando a tocar el piano.
Los patrones del comportamiento,
que inicialmente están
bajo control consciente,
se vuelven automáticos mediante un
proceso de práctica repetida.
Al principio, cuando
aprendieron a manejar,
tenían que pensar con cuidado
qué hacer con sus pies y con sus manos.
Quienes hayan tomado clases de
baile en la secundaria saben
que al principio tenían que
contar: "1, 2..."
No voy a bailar porque esto va a
quedar por siempre en el Internet.
[risas]
Pero quienes aprendieron a
bailar en la primaria
saben que ese comportamiento
que al principio estaba
bajo control consciente después
se volvió automático,
de tal forma que quienes hayan
tomado clases de vals o tango,
al escuchar esa música
tendrán una especie de rutina
motriz activada en sus pies.
El hecho de que esto pase
inevitablemente
a los seres biológicos como
nosotros, nos da una herramienta
para transformar obligaciones
normativas en leyes descriptivas.
En mi caso, algo que empezó
como una norma "ver hacia ambos lados
de la calle antes de cruzar",
ahora es una descripción de mí
y siempre veo hacia ambos
lados antes de cruzar.
Quienes hayan ido a
Inglaterra o Australia,
países en los que se maneja del lado
izquierdo en vez del derecho,
saben lo difícil que es dominar
ese hábito arraigado.
Cuando estoy en Inglaterra,
veo hacia ambos lados como 30 veces,
porque me desorienta que mi rutina
no se corresponda con la
situación a la que me enfrento.
Si aprendieron a manejar en
un carro estándar
o uno automático y cambian al otro
es muy difícil acostumbrarse.
Cuando nos habituamos a cierto
patrón de comportamiento,
lo que al principio era una regla
normativa se vuelve una descriptiva.
De hecho, uno de los principales
objetivos de criar a los hijos
es inculcarles respuestas instintivas
acordes con las obligaciones reflexivas.
Quiero que cuando le dé algo a mi
hijo, de forma automática,
sin tener que pensarlo, me
diga "gracias".
La misma capacidad que nos
permite transformar
obligaciones normativas,
aprobadas reflexivamente,
en prácticas habituales
también se puede usar
para reforzar los hábitos que
nos queremos quitar.
Muchos de nosotros al
encender la computadora
tenemos el impulso inmediato de
abrir el navegador de Internet
y el Facebook.
En la primera clase hablamos de
una forma de evitar esto
que consiste en eliminar la conexión
que nos lleva de prender nuestra
computadora a abrir el Facebook.
Si apagan su navegador de Internet,
aunque su acción sea muy instintiva,
no podrán responder a su impulso.
Si tienen la tendencia instintiva
de abrir su refrigerador
a media noche y tomarse la leche entera
de chocolate que tienen ahí,
si se deshacen de la leche, no
tendrán que cambiar el hábito.
Una de las estrategias de
autorregulación
implica limitar el acceso a la
respuesta que quieren eliminar.
Pero a veces no queremos eliminar
la respuesta totalmente.
¿Verdad? No quiero deshacerme de
toda la comida en mi cocina.
Algunos no quieren deshacerse totalmente
del acceso a Internet en
sus computadoras.
En la clase de hoy
veremos otras estrategias
para romper el enlace
entre los hábitos no deseados
o entre los impulsos
y los hábitos no deseados que generan.
Saquen sus clickers, por favor.
Es la única parte en la que vamos
a usar los clickers hoy,
pero prometo que en las próximas
clases los vamos a usar más.
Mi pregunta es: ¿Cuál de estas
afirmaciones es cierta para ustedes?
¿No tienen comportamientos
habituales que les gustaría cambiar?
¿Son completamente perfectos?
¿Son como el personaje del primer
capítulo de Alan Kazdin
que quiere cambiar a todos
pero que no necesita cambiar
nada de sí mismo?
¿O les gustaría cambiar por lo menos
algún comportamiento habitual?
La votación estará abierta
durante 6, 5, 4, 3, 2...
tenemos 110 respuestas.
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Entonces, el 8% son perfectos.
Estoy muy contenta.
Siempre he querido tener una clase
llena de gente perfecta.
Por lo menos tengo...
Supongo que son los que están
atrás en la esquina izquierda.
Pero el 92% tiene por lo menos un
hábito que le gustaría cambiar.
El 92% que tiene un hábito que
le gustaría cambiar,
responda a la segunda pregunta.
Quienes se hayan deshecho de un hábito
o hayan pensado en hacerlo,
¿cuál opción es cierta?
Fueron capaces de cambiar ese
comportamiento habitual
solo pensando: "¿Sabes qué?
Ya nunca voy a conectarme a
Internet durante la clase".
"¿Sabes qué? De verdad voy a
practicar el violín
todas las mañanas a las 10".
"¿Sabes qué? No voy a dejar mi cama
destendida en las mañanas".
¿Cuántos pudieron cambiar su hábito
simplemente proponiéndoselo?
¿Cuántos no pudieron
cambiar su hábito
simplemente proponiéndoselo?
La votación está abierta
durante 10 segundos más.
Ok. Veamos cómo salen los resultados.
4, 3, 2, 1.
Ok. ¡Dios mío!
El 35% puede cambiar sus
hábitos proponiéndoselo.
Pero el otro 65% personifican el
tipo de seres humanos
a los que va dirigida esta clase.
Ok. Es muy común,
aunque no siempre es así,
que el simple hecho de
proponernos deshacernos
de un comportamiento no
deseado es muy difícil.
El capítulo que leímos de
Jonathan Haidt y las lecturas
que hemos hecho durante todo el
semestre explican el porqué.
Un motivo por el que al menos el 65%
está en la categoría de personas
incapaces de deshacerse de un
hábito cuando se lo propone
es porque no estamos compuestos
de razón únicamente.
Platón nos dio la metáfora de la
razón, el espíritu y el apetito.
Haidt nos da la metáfora del
jinete y el elefante.
Todos los autores que hemos leído
hasta ahora nos han explicado
las formas en que
procesamos fundamentalmente
la información a un nivel
racional que puede llegar o no
a los otros aspectos de lo que
Platón denomina nuestra alma.
En las 5 fabulosas páginas de
conclusiones que les pedí leer
del libro de Ética a Nicómaco, en los
últimos fragmentos del libro,
Aristóteles escribe: "Si los argumentos
fueran suficientes en sí mismos
para que la gente fuera decente,
las recompensas que darían serían,
sin duda, muchas y muy grandes".
Pero destaca que en la
mayoría de los casos,
decirle a la gente "¿Sabes
qué? Tal vez deberías
pagar tus impuestos a
mediados de primavera"
no es suficiente para lograr que
actúen como ellos quieren
o como tú quieres que actúen.
Los argumentos por sí mismos
apelan solo a la razón
y funcionan en casos excepcionales.
Pero no siempre funcionan.
Debido a que le he quitado importancia
en la mayoría de los textos
que hemos estado leyendo de
los autores antiguos,
quiero destacar que los
textos intermedios,
los que me estoy saltando en
el resto de 1179,
expresan algo que está
en todos los textos griegos
antiguos que hemos leído,
expresan cierto tipo de
elitismo cultural
sobre la diferencia entre los
nacidos en buena cuna y el resto.
Ahora no quiero prestar atención a
eso que es un terreno legítimo
para cuestionar algunas cosas
que dice Aristóteles
y quiero centrarme en lo que considero
cierto de sus observaciones,
el hecho de que es imposible
cambiar con argumentos aquello
que tenemos asimilado desde hace mucho
tiempo por nuestros hábitos.
Aristóteles continúa discutiendo
algo que analizaremos
dentro de 5 semanas.
Concretamente, como en los humanos
la experiencia previa da forma al
comportamiento posterior
y poner reglas puede dar forma
al comportamiento prosocial,
parece que hay implicaciones
sobre cómo se deberían
estructurar las sociedades.
Cuando lleguemos a la unidad de
filosofía política,
volveremos a ver estas últimas
páginas de Ética a Nicómaco.
Quiero destacar que existe una
conexión extraordinaria
entre lo que dice Aristóteles
en este texto antiguo...
Aquí vemos una hermosa edición del
siglo XV de Ética en Latín
y la traducción que estamos usando.
Quiero explicar en el resto de la clase
que la visión fundamental de la
ética de Aristóteles
es la base de la literatura de cierto
tipo de práctica terapéutica,
en especial la terapia cognitiva
conductual, y quiero que vean
por qué puede interpretarse como una
especie de libro de autoayuda.
En específico, una guía
para criar a los hijos.
Lo que quiero decir es que Ética a
Nicómaco de Aristóteles
es la mejor guía para padres que se
ha escrito en la historia.
Quienes estén buscando un regalo
porque acaba de nacer algún sobrino o
sobrina, ya no busquen más.
[risas]
Quiero contextualizar la terapia
cognitiva conductual comenzando
con una discusión de la
literatura animal
a la cual pertenece.
La terapia conductual aprovecha que
somos seres evolucionados
de un continuo con animales no humanos
y que tenemos tipos de control del
comportamiento en común.
Pido disculpas a quienes ya han
cursado Psicología 110,
porque haré una introducción al
condicionamiento pavloviano.
¡Ah! Lo siento.
Sin disculparme con nadie aquí hay
más citas de Aristóteles.
Aristóteles dice: "Aprendemos un
oficio produciendo el mismo
producto que debemos producir
cuando ya lo hemos aprendido.
Nos volvemos constructores,
construyendo; arpistas, tocando el
arpa".
Cuando Aristóteles dice esto destaca
la importancia de estructurar
sus experiencias de tal forma
que tengan la oportunidad
de realizar el comportamiento
que desean cultivar.
Dense la oportunidad de hacer
las cosas que quieren
que se vuelvan habituales y esas
cosas se volverán habituales.
Bien. Aquí está el perro.
Supongo que la mayoría ya lo sabe,
pero vale la pena repetirlo,
existe una técnica para regular
el comportamiento animal
que obviamente se conoce desde
hace miles de años.
Hay informes de entrenamiento
de animales domésticos
en la tradición griega
antigua, de hecho, Descartes
tiene un gran estudio sobre
cómo entrenar perros.
Descartes tenía opiniones
idiosincrásicas sobre los animales.
Pensaba que eran máquinas.
Pero con respecto a esta hipótesis,
esa suposición equivocada
no hace diferencia.
Según el condicionamiento clásico,
antes de hacer el condicionamiento se
debe identificar un artículo,
por ejemplo, la comida, que
produzca una respuesta
de salivación o entusiasmo en el ser
al que se quiere condicionar.
El perro ve la comida y piensa: "Mmmm".
En este caso, la comida es lo que
los psicólogos llaman
un estímulo incondicionado.
Es algo que sin nuestra
intervención produce en el ser
al que queremos condicionar una
respuesta incondicionada.
Le muestran la comida
y sin su intervención el perro saliva.
Por el contrario, existen
muchas cosas en el mundo,
como las campanas,
que no producen ninguna
reacción en el perro.
Tocan una campana.
El perro piensa: "Un ruido. Me da
igual. Es una campana".
En ese caso, presentan un
estímulo neutral
y lo que obtienen del perro se
denomina no respuesta.
Ahora viene el condicionamiento:
le presentan al perro de forma
simultánea la campana y la comida.
La presencia de la comida es suficiente
para producir en el perro la
reacción "mmmm".
¿Verdad? El perro piensa:
"¡Comida! ¡Saliva! ¡Excelente!
¡Delicioso! ¡Algo para comer!".
Han creado una pareja de
estímulos, la campana y la comida,
y el resultado de presentar la
pareja de estímulos
es una respuesta
incondicionada que, en este
punto,
es una respuesta a la comida.
Pero los animales son seres asociativos.
Finalmente, esta respuesta
incondicionada de "mmmm"
que resulta de la integración de la
introducción de la comida,
se aparea con el estímulo neutral.
Cuando eso pasa,
cuando la campana produce en el perro
la respuesta de salivación,
hemos logrado condicionar el estímulo
para producir en el animal una
respuesta condicionada.
Esto no es posible
únicamente en los animales.
En las primeras páginas del libro
de Alan Kazdin que leímos,
vimos la historia del pobre bebé Albert
que no tenía ningún problema
con los conejos blancos
hasta que el estímulo neutral de
un conejo blanco se apareó
con el estímulo incondicionado de un
fuerte ruido que le daba miedo.
Entonces Albert asoció
aquello que antes era
neutral, el conejo blanco,
con un sentimiento de miedo.
Los seres humanos son capaces
de tener asociaciones
con valores positivos o negativos
que producen en ellos respuestas
emocionales positivas o negativas.
Y son capaces de tener esas asociaciones
con entidades que antes no
tenían valor para ellos.
Con esto en mente,
los psicólogos comenzaron a
pensar más generalmente
en la relación entre los objetos y los
comportamientos, por una parte,
y los resultados a los que se asocian
esos objetos o
comportamientos, por otra
parte.
El condicionamiento clásico se ocupa
del consumo pasivo de algún
artículo en el mundo:
se les presenta comida o un conejo
y surge una determinada asociación.
Mientras que el condicionamiento
operante se ocupa de la relación
entre los comportamientos
que ustedes tienen
y los resultados que dichos
comportamientos suelen dar.
En nuestro repertorio de
comportamientos tenemos
un montón de cosas que son
comportamientos deseados.
Tienen comportamientos deseados como
cumplir con sus lecturas,
ir al gimnasio, ser educados con
sus compañeros habitación
y llamar a sus padres una
vez por semana.
Y también tenemos
comportamientos no deseados.
Cosas que desearíamos no hacer.
Los malos hábitos que tenemos
el 92% de los presentes.
Los psicólogos han descubierto
que podemos usar los mecanismos
del condicionamiento
para incrementar de forma diferencial
varios tipos de comportamiento.
Si prestamos atención a las
consecuencias que suelen tener
los comportamientos e
intervenimos para controlarlas,
podemos aumentar la incidencia de
ciertos tipos de comportamientos
y disminuir la incidencia de otros.
Si existe un comportamiento deseado
que les gustaría aumentar,
pueden aparear ese
comportamiento con una
consecuencia
que actúe como refuerzo.
Lo pueden aparear con un
refuerzo positivo.
Puedo darles un refuerzo positivo
por sus esfuerzos de escribir
un ensayo: una carta para
sus expedientes
con un valor notable para sus
futuros empleadores.
Puedo proporcionarles un
refuerzo positivo
para un comportamiento deseado.
También podemos reforzar un
comportamiento deseado
mediante un refuerzo negativo.
Eliminar un estímulo aversivo.
Si hay ruido en la sala,
reciben un refuerzo negativo a su
tendencia de ponerse tapones
si al ponerse los tapones se reduce
la consecuencia desagradable
de estar en una sala ruidosa.
Podemos aumentar los
comportamientos que queremos
si los asociamos con las
consecuencias que incrementan
subjetivamente el valor de ese
comportamiento para el individuo,
apareando algo que ya le gusta al
individuo con ese comportamiento.
También podemos disminuir
la probabilidad
de un comportamiento no
deseado o deseado asociando
dicho comportamiento con alguna
consecuencia negativa.
Podemos quitarles algo que les gusta
si actúan de una forma que no queremos.
En las últimas dos clases, antes o
después de las vacaciones de marzo,
hablaremos del castigo y
de cómo funciona.
Los comportamientos pueden asociarse
con consecuencias positivas o negativas.
A veces, esto pasa de forma natural.
Cuando como pastel de
chocolate eso se asocia
con la consecuencia positiva
del sabor que me da.
Se refuerza positivamente
porque el comportamiento
de comer el pastel da lugar a la
consecuencia natural del sabor del pastel.
Es posible que no me dé cuenta
que ese comportamiento también da
lugar a una consecuencia
que no valoro tan positivamente.
Aumenta la cantidad de
oclusiones en las arterias
que van a mi corazón.
Hacer que la gente se dé cuenta
de las consecuencias negativas
naturales de sus comportamientos
es una forma de usar este paradigma.
Podemos tomar los
comportamientos que tenemos,
los que queremos aumentar, y asociarlos
con consecuencias positivas.
Podemos tomar los
comportamientos que tenemos,
los que queremos aumentar, y asociarlos
con consecuencias negativas.
Podemos ayudar a que la
gente sea consciente
de las consecuencias
positivas o negativas
que esos comportamientos ya tienen.
Por último, podemos descubrir
que, sin darnos cuenta,
un cierto tipo de refuerzo
está conservando un
comportamiento que no queremos.
Los padres pueden descubrir
que un niño lloriquea
porque ese comportamiento no deseado
está asociado con un refuerzo que es
la atención de los padres.
Y podrían reconocer que
eliminar ese refuerzo
reducirá el comportamiento.
El condicionamiento operante
toma nuestra capacidad de asociación
y la usa de formas conocidas
para aumentar los
comportamientos deseados
y disminuir los no deseados.
Por supuesto, los
comportamientos no surgen de la
nada.
En tercer lugar, el
condicionamiento operante
se ocupa de los antecedentes que dan
lugar a los comportamientos.
La probabilidad de que se
presente un comportamiento
depende en primer lugar de los
acontecimientos del entorno.
En los casos en que el refuerzo
puede aumentar la probabilidad
de que el comportamiento se presente,
tendrán más probabilidades de beber
leche de chocolate en la noche
cuando tengan hambre.
Si se toman un vaso de
agua una hora antes,
el refuerzo de la leche de
chocolate no será tan grande.
Pueden establecer las circunstancias
para aumentar o disminuir la
eficacia de los refuerzos.
También pueden proporcionarse
o proporcionar estímulos a los demás.
Yo quiero ayudarlos a que
cumplan con sus lecturas,
entonces les proporciono
guías para dirigirlos
a las partes del texto que
considero más importantes,
así reduzco las barreras de entrada
que pudieran tener las lecturas.
Ayudo a provocar el comportamiento
haciendo la tarea más fácil.
Por último, podemos
incrementar el comportamiento
diferencialmente mediante la
presencia o ausencia
de un estímulo
discriminativo, que
indica,
en términos técnicos, la
disponibilidad de un refuerzo.
En el texto que leímos para hoy,
Alan Kazdin destaca que
si el comportamiento que nos interesa
es contestar nuestro teléfono,
el timbre del teléfono
es un antecedente
que hace más probable que el
comportamiento aumente el refuerzo.
El refuerzo es poder hablar con
la persona que nos llama.
Están con su teléfono.
Si el teléfono suena, hay una
razón para contestarlo.
Si el teléfono no suena, no hay
una razón para contestarlo.
El marco del condicionamiento
operante proporciona una forma
de aprovechar la sugerencia de
Aristóteles de estructurar
nuestras vidas para que los
comportamientos que queremos
en nuestro repertorio se
vuelvan habituales.
Una de las formas más
efectivas de hacerlo
es estructurar la experiencia para que
el comportamiento no deseado
sea incompatible con el
comportamiento alternativo
que ponemos en su lugar.
En el contexto de criar a los
hijos, Alan Kazdin indica que
en vez de pensar en los comportamientos
que no queremos que tengan
nuestros hijos, por ejemplo,
no queremos que lloriqueen, que
peleen entre hermanos,
que estén despiertos
después de la media noche;
es mejor pensar en los
comportamientos que sí queremos
y premiarlos.
En vez de pensar "no quiero
pasarme la noche
hablando con mi compañero de
cuarto y desvelarme", mejor
piensen "¿cuál es el comportamiento
que quiero cultivar o reforzar?
¿Qué alternativa evitará que
actúe como no quiero
y me motivará para actuar
como sí quiero?"
Así, se brindan la oportunidad de
tener la forma más profunda
y duradera de autocontrol humano.
Una forma de autocontrol humano
que aprovecha la diferencia
entre aquello que les indica la razón
y aquello que les pide su
espíritu y su apetito.
Llegan a asociar con
consecuencias positivas
un comportamiento que antes
no tenían reforzado.
Kazdin dice: "cuando te
deshaces de un comportamiento
premiando el comportamiento opuesto,
los efectos son más fuertes
y duran más que si castigaras el
comportamiento no deseado.
La mejor manera de construir el
comportamiento que quieres
es mediante la práctica reforzada".
Esto de que "la mejor
manera de construir
el comportamiento que quieres es
mediante la práctica reforzada"
es algo que seguramente ya
han escuchado antes.
De hecho, ya lo han escuchado
tres veces en esta clase.
"Aprendemos un oficio
produciendo el mismo producto
que debemos producir cuando ya
hemos aprendido el oficio.
Nos volvemos
constructores,
construyendo.
Nos volvemos arpistas, tocando el arpa".
En el reto de Aristóteles
y en su analogía contemporánea,
intentamos estructurar nuestras vidas
para poder tomar las
obligaciones normativas,
las cosas que son buenas ideas, y
convertirlas en descripciones
de comportamientos que sean
naturales para nosotros.
Pasan de ser buenas ideas a ser leyes.
Creo que esto también proporciona
una nueva visión del pasaje
con el que terminé la clase anterior.
Aristóteles escribe que:
"Abstenernos de los placeres
nos proporciona templanza y una
vez que tenemos templanza,
somos más capaces de
abstenernos de los placeres.
Algo parecido pasa con la valentía.
Habituarnos a mantenernos firmes
ante situaciones de miedo
nos hace valientes y una vez que
nos hemos vuelto valientes,
somos más capaces de
mantenernos firmes".
Creo que esto es un aspecto
innegable de la naturaleza humana.
Pero no es la historia completa.
Los dos ensayos que leeremos
para la siguiente clase
destacan una complicación de la
historia que he mencionado hoy,
nos piden que reflexionemos si
esto describe por completo
lo que se requiere para
provocar el cambio
que esperamos lograr.
Tengo muchas ganas de explicarles
esos textos el jueves.